[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MARK MOFFETT: Bella,
thank you so much.
I'm an escape artist.
I guess everyone at Google
is a form of escape artist,
but I escape to remote
places all the time.
If you want to find your
way to some tribal group
or see the world's weirdest
slug, just talk to me.
I'll find the answers
that you need.
And over the years,
I've just continued
to do what I did when
I was a child, which
is just look for things I
like, wherever they are.
And Geographic has given
me opportunities for that
and other research venues.
And I just keep going.
And during all that time, I've
spent a fair amount of days
with both creatures that
have interesting societies
and human tribal groups
and hunter-gatherer groups.
And I began to think about
how those groups form and stay
together over time,
and what that means.
So for the last six
years, I've been a hermit.
Melissa has put up with
me being at home in front
of the computer, too often.
She's in the back, there.
We'll give her
round of applause,
so we can not have to
repeat it at the end.
[APPLAUSE]
And so I have been Mr.
Boring for too long.
When this book is out, which
was yesterday, I will disappear.
I'm giving you the chance to
see me, then I'm like Flash--
out of here.
Well, I'm stuck giving
a few more talks.
But in any case, this is a book
now called "The Human Swarm,
How Our Societies Arise,
Thrive, And Fall."
And we all know what a human
society is, but in brief, it's
a well-defined group
with specific members,
with a strong feeling of
allegiance, and often a feeling
that you can fight for and
even die for that group.
Societies last through
the generations,
and we expect membership
in them to be involuntary.
And when you think of
societies in that way,
you'll see that a number of
animals have societies, too--
meerkats, for example.
And then there are insects with
societies, like the honeybee.
And what makes societies
alike and different?
And what this says
about humans is really
what this book is about.
And to get this in
a nutshell, I want
you to consider the most
remarkable thing in the world.
It is across the
street from Google.
It is a Starbucks.
Now, you can walk
into a Starbucks
and not instantly want to kill
everyone, run away in terror,
or at least walk up
to every individual
and find out who they are
and what they're doing.
This is something
pretty unique to humans
across the vertebrate animals.
A chimpanzee could not do this.
A chimpanzee would
go on a killing spree
or just try to get out of
there as fast as possible.
The difference is that chimps
do not allow for strangers,
whereas humans can deal with
strangers, hundreds of them,
and of course, in New York,
potentially tens of thousands
of them a day.
And nothing bad happens.
So how did this come about?
I argue that this
is a pivotal turning
point in human evolution
that's been really ignored.
And it's a part
of our brain that
eventually led to the
possibility of having nations.
Now, to give you a reference
point for the argument,
I'm going to speak to the Social
Brain Hypothesis, which has
gotten a fair amount of news.
You've probably heard of it.
It's this idea you can
have about 150 friends,
and this is an assessment
based on our brain size.
Chimpanzees can have a
smaller number of allies.
Humans can have more.
The idea is that our brains
are largely big in order
to increase our social
networks, because they're
so expensive to maintain.
But the idea ends
up with a problem.
And Robert Dunbar, who
came up with this notion,
addressed this problem
or at least mentioned it
when he first proposed it.
And that is shown here.
It's from this original paper.
"How is it that, despite the
apparent cognitive constraints
on group size, modern human
societies are nonetheless
able to form super-large
groups, nation states."
What is it about us?
What holds us together?
So I just want you to think
about this immense breakthrough
in our past.
It seems so simple,
and it's ended up
allowing a huge number of people
to be together, and assess
each other, and even
relate across societies.
At the same time, it's given
us all kinds of social baggage
that we have to deal with.
And yet, I don't
think we're ever going
to be able to lose societies.
There's some arguments
that we should,
but it's not going to happen.
Societies give us a sense
of meaning and validation,
and they're a yearning
that's very, very
basic to our psychology.
It's deeply rooted within us.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
I went a couple of minutes long,
but are there any questions
out there?
AUDIENCE: Hi there, Dr. Mark.
Thanks so much for
that presentation.
It was really
interesting to learn
the parts you talked about
identifying different societies
in humans and others.
It made me think that
is it true for humans
that what purpose or
benefit of a human society
is the ability to make
assumptions about the person
that you identify in it?
MARK MOFFETT: Yes, and those
are, of course, biases.
And those kind of biases are
linked to our categorization
of others.
And I didn't go
into those issues,
but a big part of
the book is looking
at how those categorizations
work, which include not just
societies, but now ethnic
groups and races within them.
So we take a continuum and carve
it up very, very efficiently,
and we don't allow
for intermediates.
We make assumptions about
who belongs and who doesn't.
AUDIENCE: So humans
seem to engage
in an interesting
activity, whereby
we go to other societies.
And they see us being different,
and they don't kill us.
And sometimes, we buy things
from them, like tourism.
Are we the only species that
does something like that,
or do you see that
in other animals,
even if they're invertebrates?
MARK MOFFETT: No, invertebrates
don't do that at all.
Invertebrates are all about us.
They kill them.
Humans are amazing for
the degree of our ability
to take in other
identities and assess them
as potential partners.
And things like bonobos can get
together and groom each other,
but they don't form an alliance
to take over the third bonobo
troop over there
that they don't like
or to figure out how
to collect something
from a tree or anything.
None of these alliance type
things that happen in humans
are found anywhere else.
The closest possibility
are the sperm whales,
where two societies can
apparently get together
and hunt together more
efficiently sometimes
for squid-- they eat squid--
than they can separately.
So they may be able to work
together in the sperm whale.
But it's obviously
a big cognitive leap
and an interesting part
of the whole story.
AUDIENCE: Mark?
MARK MOFFETT: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do ant colonies at war
allocate resources differently,
or is it just a boundary
condition between colonies?
MARK MOFFETT: Ant
colonies at war?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MARK MOFFETT: They
don't allocate.
We don't know that.
That'd be interesting to know.
What is clear is that
warfare arises in ants.
And in fact, I did an article
for "Scientific American"
on ants and the art of
war, showing that there
are all kinds of parallels.
And the very
existence of warfare,
which is a mass phenomenon where
both sides face catastrophe--
so it's not a one sided thing.
If you look at war-- and that's
what we usually mean by war--
those kinds of
aggression occur when
societies get tens of
thousands or bigger
in both humans and ants.
And once you have more and more
individuals in the society,
the per capita cost goes down.
There are lots of
studies showing that.
And so you end up
with this labor pool,
and you just sit around and be
used for things like battles
or, in the case of
humans, diverted
into arts and sciences.
Luckily, we don't just
use them for battles.
But arguably, you need
a large population.
But whether they allocate things
differently when they actually
have the battle, no one knows.
AUDIENCE: So it seems
like human society
is able to evolve on markers.
So if you think
of nation states,
we're able to evolve
what that means
and what groups
count in it and not.
Is there a parallel
in the animal world?
Like are ants able to change
their trails as members join
or as history happens?
MARK MOFFETT: Well,
ironically, the one case
where this is known well
is in the slavery ants.
And they are ants
that take slaves,
and they take slaves
that are young ants.
And those ants
emerge in a colony.
And like a baby chick
learning who its mother is,
they learn the identity
of their society.
But those slaves were taken
from a different colony,
so they don't have
the same scent.
And it turns out,
all the ants are
grooming each other all the
time and probably exchanging
the scent.
And so it is allowed to
live just because it's
conforming to this scent.
But that means the scent itself
is changing all the time.
And there are other
cases as well,
showing that ants are
actually quite smart,
despite the tiny brain, at
tracking what the scent is.
And they never make mistakes.
And if that slave goes
out and encounters
its mother's colony, where
it should be, it's attacked.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
how societies are temporary
and there's an identity
split and a society split,
at some point.
So if you think about Google
itself like a society--
we have like 100,000 people--
what lessons would there be
for a company like Google,
where you have all these people
that have to work together?
MARK MOFFETT: Yeah.
Well, legally,
large corporations
are treated like
individuals, sometimes.
In fact, they have
some properties
of societies, like this
identity unity and so forth.
Whether they stay
through the generations--
so since I had for
the original IBM
that their grandkids would
still be working for it--
is maybe a missing
part of that parallel.
But basically, it's hard to say.
Within the corporate
level, no one's
looked at things in
the corporate level.
Actually, someone should to see
how corporations often split
apart and so forth over time.
I really can't answer
that in detail,
but it's a very good question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: What are your thoughts
on, like for humans, not ants
here, the rise of intercultural,
interracial marriages
and relationships?
Do you see this
forming new societies,
or is this just blending
different traditions?
Because it seems like
we're able to do this
a lot more easily
now than in the past.
Do you have any
thoughts on that?
MARK MOFFETT: Yeah.
Well, it's really interesting.
There's this thought that
the whole world is getting
Americanized by
movies, and McDonald's,
and McDonaldization, or
whatever that's called.
In any case, when you look
through the literature,
the sense is that the societies
stay staunchly separate.
In fact, they may increase
their differences.
Places like China are
perhaps even more Chinese
than they were before, because
one's need for the help
of outsiders actually
often causes the in-group
to become more rigid,
and more set in its ways,
and more distinctive.
That doesn't mean you're
not relating to each other
all the time in a useful way,
but the societies stay stable
throughout those processes.
And the interesting part--
another part of your question
was about people
between societies
and so forth linking up.
And one of the amazing
things about humans
is we are able to
take individuals
from other societies, and
they can join our own.
So in the past, it would have
been refugees or marriage
partners.
As I said at the beginning,
a certain number of people
have to transfer
between societies just
to interbreed when our
societies were small.
In the case of
humans, that means
they had to take on certain
attributes of the group
that they're joining.
So they'd have to learn language
and some of the behaviors,
but they'd never
be perfect at it.
We can never completely
drop our identities.
So even today, we see with
immigrants after two or three
or four generations, there'll
be a lot of nuances taken on,
maybe even their walking
style and so forth.
But there's still a
sense of difference,
and that's maintained, actually,
by the rules of the society.
I won't go into it,
but this yin and yang
of belonging and being different
is a really interesting part
of the whole human dynamics.
It's amazing it works.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So the societies
that you present
seem to be very based
on physical proximity.
And I'm wondering if you see any
trends, in humans especially,
of creating societies
that are not
based on this kind of
proximity or territory?
MARK MOFFETT: Yes.
Actually, there are cases.
The most interesting cases
in the animal kingdom
are the ones that aren't
based on proximity.
Things like wolves, and
elephants, and chimpanzees
can spread over the landscape
and still remember each other.
And in fact, they can remember
each other sometimes for years.
And this capacity to
retain relationships
over the long term is
amplified in humans,
because our early
societies, particularly,
were highly spread out.
And you might not see
somebody for years,
and they might look different.
They've aged, certainly.
Or you might meet a
complete stranger,
and yet you can be
comfortable with them
within moments, as long
as they weren't angry.
They can be people you don't
want to deal with that day.
But this capacity for
dynamics over space and time
is what really makes
humans different from a lot
of these species to a different
degree than the others.
AUDIENCE: In terms of like
they're still contiguous,
it seems.
Can I be embedded in
another set of people
and be a member of a
society somewhere else?
MARK MOFFETT: Well, it's
an interesting question,
because basically, there's
not a lot of information
from psychology on some
of these possibilities.
It seems to be if we're part
of two different societies,
we tend to have a stronger
relationship with one of them
and see ourselves more different
and distinct from the other.
Not to go directly
into an ant example,
but I will go directly
into an ant example.
And that is the very
large colony that's
taken over Southern
California, most of it,
with a trillion individuals,
controls all the port cities
of Southern California,
and it's boarded the ships.
And it's now the
same colony that's
conquered 1,000 miles of
the European coastline.
You can take an ant from
California to Europe,
and it's just fine.
You can take it to
parts of Europe,
where other colonies have
gotten in, and it's killed.
So these ants are
actually expanding
at a global level as societies,
giving it sort of a situation
like Alaska and Hawaii is
from the continental US--
a continuum with leap
frogs from place to place.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: One for
work and society,
I have a particular
question regarding humans.
The examples you gave with
the animals and insects,
they always have, some of them,
a specific feature that drive
them most-- division or unity.
In humans, in your
research, what
is the feature
characteristic in us
that drives division or unity?
Do you have like a top?
MARK MOFFETT: Well, it
seems to vary a lot.
I was looking a lot through the
early anthropology literature,
because many anthropologists
don't even think
hunter-gatherers had societies.
And that's because they're
looking at hunter-gatherers
today that are embedded in
other societies themselves.
But if you look at
the early societies,
you can see that there would
be branches spread out.
And there'd be 1,000
or 2,000 people
that would share this identity.
And how this is
maintained over time
and what causes the breakdown
is the big question.
Sometimes, you hear
the stories about it
being very little things, like
someone insulted some aspect
of some ritual or something.
And sometimes, it seems
to be about big things.
It's really hard to say what
gets people excited sometimes.
But clearly, the last step--
you know there's
trouble when one
of these subgroups
within the society
gives itself its own name.
Names are important.
Once you have your
own name, you're
probably on the way
out or the way in,
depending on whether you want
to be in that group or not.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE]
MARK MOFFETT: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: One of the things
that I find really interesting
about human evolution is
our relationship with dogs
and how we, as a species,
co-evolved with dogs
in forming those relationships
to the point that today,
you could say that they
really are part of our society
rather than just us
using them as tools.
I was curious as to your
opinion on that relationship.
MARK MOFFETT: Yeah,
I think they can
be viewed as part of society.
I had a paragraph about this.
It's one of these
little things that
had to get out of the book.
But once you're
totally interlinked,
and your identity is
interlinked with theirs,
by the definition of looking
at society's identity,
dogs become part of,
at least, our families,
but also our societies.
And it's the same with
human crops, which
are totally dependent on
us, and even ant crops,
as leaf-cutter ants
are agricultural.
And so their crops
are only found
with their particular nest.
That nest has a relationship
with that particular breed
of crop and will
kill anything that
looks identical to us
that comes from outside.
SPEAKER: Thank you
so much for coming,
and thank you to Dr. Moffett
for your presentation, today.
MARK MOFFETT: Thanks.
It was sort of a practice run.
So let me know anything you
liked, and you can email me
there with any thoughts.